salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien alors aujourd'hui je voulais
vous parler à nouveau de laurie que
j'avais rencontrés sur la colline du
crack alors pour ceux qu'on passe suivi
des soins depuis le début je vous invite
à aller voir les trois précédentes
épisode qui illustre youtube je vous
mets les liens en description
du craj surprise à 15 ans des jo en
braille d'alcool on va lire n'importe
quoi
alors l'origine suivi pendant deux ans
d'abord sur la colline lorsqu'elle était
dépendante au crack et qu'elle suis
prostitué cité du côté d'aubry
bah les bandes
l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
et ensuite chez sa mère en belgique
quand elle est tombée enceinte cheikh
ben son chef ce que j'attends un bébé
alors laurie elle a complètement arrêté
le crack depuis un les retourner atari
vivre avec sa fille dans un hôtel social
et beaucoup de choses ont changé dans sa
vie
tu commences à filmer ouais je vais
petit réglage et commence
bon je fixe
nous expliquer ce qui s'est passé que la
dernière fois mais ben du coup voilà
j'étais retourné chez ma mère
ensuite après je suis retourné à paris
j'ai accouché à paris ils ont fait plein
de tests sur elle et sur moi pour voir
si jamais je me droguais plus fort si
jamais ma fille n'avait pas de trace de
drogue c'est la panique et donc ils ont
vu qu'en fait elle avait rien du tout
elle était tout à fait normal donc du
coup ils me l'ont laissé trouvais cela
vire
bois
pour faire couler le banc parce que je
vous explique un hôtel 215 600
kg fabriquer un système
alawaji j'avoue mais voilà j'ai coupé
est en fait vous voyez face mais comme
ça la logique godard
k
j'habite vraiment bien de ce qu'on m'a
aidé à la maternité 30
c'est je suis pas 12 dans la vie avec
rien c'est pas avec elle
celle qui m'a appris à edou c'est elle
qui m'a appris à prendre un petit peu de
patiente dont tous réfugiés de la
passion je précise
qu'elle attrape froid
et comment tu réagirais si jamais
elle par exemple elle a consommé du
crack à l'adolescence les choses comme
il s'agirait à rechercher
souvent je pense à tout ça dit [ __ ] si
jamais celle par mois si jamais il
reprend
je crois que je suis sûr qu'il ya plein
de choses que je n'aurais pas du tout
comme mes parents
n'ont pas à pleurer
j'ai peur que quand ma fille grandisse
bain des questions par rapport à ça est
ce que tu vas lire répond ben je vais le
dire que voilà maman elle avait elle a
vraiment de sa vie où elle était perdu
jusque quand elle a appris qu elle était
enceinte elle a eu l'impression de se
retrouver grâce à elle
bon bah tu as mangé une pizza non c'est
toi qui paye ta du baril dessous
tu viens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment maison un enfant
pour les gens qu'on connaît dans l'année
ouais je veux pas que j'ai changé mes
cheveux et a beaucoup de gens qui
m'appellent marc arrive beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup
des attar et et voilà c'est pas toi là
ces enfants qui prend du crack
franchement j'ai tout eu coup et une
fois j'étais super contente elles ont
dit oui tu as arrêté j'espère que t'as
pas recommencer parce que tu es revenu à
paris on est super fiers les super
contente franchement c'est génial on
t'adore s'était trouvée
merci
c'est difficile de se libérer d'une
addiction
c'est difficile de séparer d'une
parce que sans cesse en fait même encore
à l'heure actuelle vous mais encore il
ya des fois que mon cerveau enfin je
sais pas si c'est bon mais je crois que
c'est mon cerveau qui est qui me dit
écoute avons été assez de doses là une
dose ça te ferait pas de mal à la fin
j'ai souvent voilà j'ai des envies qui
passe en fait mais pas plus que ça et
puis elles sont moins en moins fortes
avec le temps
eh ben
la vie d'avant je la voyais crise paris
je voyais que cris n'a pas beaucoup
d'emplois
[Musique]
je pressais quelques coups comme cela
y'a pas tout en entier on a mangé déjà
un petit peu mais vous en faites pas
testé on n'est pas que vino
s'explique il ya un livre ou moins qui
va sortir et je vais distribuer à des
gens qui sont dans la rue ce que je veux
avant j'étais comme toi tu vois j'ai 19
ans mais avant j'étais j'étais vraiment
depuis mes 13 ans je dormais dehors tu
vois et je fume du crack j'étais à la
colline tu vois et j'ai eu mon bébé est
ça qui m'a trouvé arrêté en faites
attention à vous
c'est trop bien parce que je peux enfin
aider les gens comme on m'a aidé
quelques semaines plus tôt il ya une
maison d'édition qui m'a appelé et qui
voulait proposer à laurie d'écrire un
roman un roman autobiographique et
c'était le rêve de lauriers puis très
longtemps d'écrire un livre du coup on a
pris rendez vous avec l'éditrice
[Applaudissements]
gardes du corps et dont je connais parc
eugène un parking
[Musique]
si je connais me sens je crois que j'ai
été dans un commissariat parle moins
mais si je connaissais l'hôpital machin
là
et à moins 4 je pense où il ya des
médicaments gratuits même et quelques
soucis non cette provoc progresser lieu
je me dis que je passe à autre chose
quoi
[Musique]
giuly bonjour merci c'est gentil
suis ravi de rencontrer va vous montrer
toutes les autres tout les droits
je peux m'asseoir
contre
laquelle âge elle a 4 ans et 12h04 règne
j'ai vraiment envie de faire mon livre
c'est vraiment le sait vraiment et est
ce que je dois mettre mon enfance où je
vais mettre que les épisodes d'or d'ici
un peu tout
mais si vous en aviez oui oui de quoi
vous avez envie pas est ce que vous avez
envie de dire est-ce que vous avez les
transmettre il ya un message très fort a
adressé tous les jeunes qui ont plongé à
tous les enfants aussi ce sont en galère
et qu'ils subissent que vous avez suivi
quand des problèmes de famille quand des
progrès des attouchements dont s'est
aussi libéré la parole pour éviter
d'arriver à se faire du mal ouais ouais
parce que je me qualifiais tout ça avant
solution pour me tue à petit feu ben
c'était me droguer parce que soit
l'instant j'étais bien et à peine deux
secondes après j'étais tue tout comment
dire si dans le speed dans le stress et
j'étais j'avais toutes mes angoisses qui
me retomber dessus est un truc de fou
mais le moment où je tirais dessus
c'était là que j'étais bien j'avais
vraiment envie de connaître
comme ça sa soeur c'est plus en moi il
ya beaucoup en moi et
c'est très courageux et on puisse enfin
je crois que j'écris bien dit oui depuis
tout petit j'ai écrit et rien à décrire
ben ça me behr en fait issues peut
expliquer ça ça ça sort et ça se met sur
une feuille c'est plus la pente
merci mali chine à très bientôt merci
[Musique]
grave ou kidnappés
pour cette ville
qu'est-ce que tu cherche je cherche mon
ami
tu l'as trouvé déjà cas mais
beaucoup de joindre à moi je suis bon
votre meilleur
c'est mon histoire qu'on
en fait j'ai pas l'impression que
j'ai pas l'impression que c'est moi je
sais pas expliquer en fait c'était moins
quelque chose de ouf
je triple jeu double
est là vraiment je me sens tout
tout en coton coin
tout défoncer sur des bases et célèbre
événement ouais je me sentais bien mais
j'ai peur aussi
mais j'ai peur parce que tout tout tout
homme tenant un livre un film quoi il ya
des critiques
ça il y aura toujours des gens pour
critiquer ton parcours mais peu de gens
sont très bien d'avoir un parcours était
ce regret comme cela fait donc son
chemin déclare inquiète pas les
critiques n'ont pas toujours critique
le miel
bonjour aux côtés
carrément d'avoir saboté toi
[Musique]
e
c'est le rallye mon coeur
[Musique]
selon faire
cet été tout le temps que l'on entré
dans le temps c'était
juste pour aller taquiner c'était
l'enfer
[Musique]
c'est quoi je vous trouvez maintenant
pas ça me fait plaisir de la course
comme ça ça me fait super plaisir parce
que l on a vécu des trucs et les plus
jeunes que moi et c'est la preuve qu'on
peut s'en sortir moi je me suis pas
totalement sortie du produit donc ces
jeunes c'est une respiration pour moi
voilà merci elle va se dévouer pas fait
trop trop plaisir je souhaite que du
bonheur et ça me fait trop plaisir de
voir comme ça chacun fait un tabac ouais
ça me fait plaisir
[Musique]
laurie c'est vraiment une miraculée et
franchement c'est vraiment incroyable
pour moi de l'avoir vu parcourir tout ce
chemin en seulement deux ans c'est
vraiment une page qui se tourne un point
elles évidemment et pour moi essayer un
petit peu quoi
fais nous tous
je ne sais pas
et si vous êtes intéressé de savoir
comment j'ai rencontré laurie la
première fois comment je suis arrivé sur
la colline du crack et comment j'ai
travaillé là bas et aussi comment j'ai
entretenu contact avec lorie au fil des
ans eh bien je raconte toutes les
coulisses des tournages dans une vidéo
sur ma chaîne youtube personnel voilà
j'espère que le reportage vous a plu à
très bientôt